[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bonsoir bonsoir à toutes et à tous et
bienvenue dans ce sens public votre
émission quotidienne de débat et de
reportage sur Public Sénat c'est parti
pour 90 minutes la promesse vous le
savez elle est dans le titre de
l'émission donner du sens à l'actualité
vous proposez des clés de compréhension
des mutations de notre société le mardi
6 juin c'est le prochain rendez-vous
donné par l'interdical pour se mobiliser
contre la réforme des retraites deux
jours plus tard les députés examineront
une proposition de loi du groupe liotte
pour abroger la réforme mais d'ici là
qui acceptera de venir à la table des
négociations avec Elizabeth borne
jusqu'où l'unité syndicale très solide
depuis quatre mois peut-être tenir et
puis la stratégie les 100 jours
d'Emmanuel Macron est-ce qu'elle trouve
un écho favorable dans l'opinion on
répond à toutes ces questions dans une
minute et puis pour notre second débat
c'est justement l'une des réformes
annoncées par le Président de la
République que l'on va décortiquer la
lutte contre eux les fraudes elles sont
par nature difficile à évaluer mais pour
la seule fraude sociale la Cour des
comptes parle d'un milliard d'euros
les cartes vitales active sont plus
nombreuses que les bénéficiaires
identifiés les fraudes liés à la pension
aux retraites suite à la non-déclaration
d'un décès sont nombreuses et n'oublions
pas les allocations versées du monde
assez frodes individuels ajoutons les
pratiques d'escroquerie sophistiquées et
répandues qui rendent ces dernières
pratiques difficiles à détecter là pour
la faute sociale le montant de la fraude
fiscale lui est 10 fois plus important
quels moyens quel contrôle quel moyen
mis en oeuvre faut-il lier arnaque aux
prestations sociales et immigration
comme l'a fait Bruno Le Maire ne ratez
pas notre second débat dans trois quarts
d'heure mais d'abord les leçons les
premières leçons de la fête du travail
avec Cécile si
la gauche ne compte pas tourner la page
des retraites et continue de mettre la
pression sur le gouvernement pour qu'il
retire sa réforme on ne fait pas taire
le peuple on l'écoute on ne le mé
[Applaudissements]
prise pas on a l'air et prime pas on lui
obéit nous ne céderons pas vous vouliez
en avoir fini le 14 juillet vous aurez
votre prise de la Bâtie vous avez déjà
perdu quand retirez-vous votre réforme
des retraites même combat pour le road
trip pour le président du groupe
socialiste au Sénat Patrick caner il
espère la validation par le Conseil
constitutionnel du référendum
d'initiative partagée déposé par des
députés et sénateurs de gauche
donc demain
j'ai la décision du Conseil
constitutionnel sur l'éventu éventualité
de lancer une procédure de
référendumistif partagé qui nous
permettrait pour ce qui nous concerne
parti politique syndicat FORCE
associative et bien de d'aller chercher
les 4 millions 800 000 signatures
nécessaires pour la procédure
côté les syndicats donneront rendez-vous
le
6 vers le monde une proposition de loi
pour abroger la réforme la page ne sera
pas tournée
[Musique]
et que nous entendons bien le 8 juin
prochain gagner labrogation de cette
réforme Laurent Berger a saisi la main
tendue d'Elizabeth borne pour revenir à
la table des discussions une perspective
d'akalmie pour le gouvernement pour
avancer sur d'autres projets de loi
comme celui du plein emploi
et on va se projeter jusqu'à cette
double échéance des 6 et 8 juin avec mes
invités Jean-Marie Pernaut bonsoir
bienvenue vous êtes politologue
chercheur associé à l'Institut de
recherche économique et social et auteur
de ce livre le syndicalisme d'après qui
est publié aux éditions Le Détour
anne-charles bonsoir bienvenue à vous
vous êtes constitutionnaliste pierre
Adrien Bartoli bonsoir bienvenue
directeur des études politiques chez
Harris Interactive et melisabethi
bonsoir Émilie spécialiste en
communication politique et éditorialiste
pour sens publique je rappelle on les a
entendus rapidement les chiffres de la
mobilisation de ce 1er mai pas comme les
autres comme toujours deux bilans celui
de la police près de 800 000
manifestants toute la France 2300 000
selon la CGT Jean-Marie Pernaut c'est
beaucoup pour un 1er mai mais c'est
moins que pour d'autres journées de
mobilisation contre la réforme des
retraites vous y voyez quoi un
affaiblissement ou une persistance
finalement de la forme puissance du
mouvement ce qui est frappant c'est
quand même qu'au bout de trois mois on
est toujours quand même des taux
impressionnants on peut après il y a
de se répondre d'une certaine façon bien
sûr il n'est pas forcément anodin non
plus qu'on est la décision du Conseil
pensionnelle demain qui soit considéré
comme une échéance pourquoi parce que
finalement on se rend bien compte que
l'Inter syndical essaye de de marteler
l'idée que le processus en fait
d'aboutissement de cette loi n'est pas
le processus d'acceptation par le peuple
et que donc il y a deux légitimités et
deux mamans à construire alors moi j'ai
quand même le sentiment que cette
manifestation d'hier vient signer la
persistance je vous rejoins assez
largement parce que quand bien même les
motivations s'essouffent quand bien même
les chiffres sont un petit peu moins
nombreux on se rend compte avec la
litanie des casseroles des sifflets etc
que il y a quand même encore de la
popularité du côté du mouvement anti
réforme et c'est là qu'on rentre dans
dans quelque chose qui est un peu de
l'ordre de la crise de communication
gouvernementale c'est que il est
important qu'à un moment donné du
calendrier le gouvernement reprenne la
main finalement ils reprennent un petit
peu le le
calendrier l'agenda de la communication
et de la légitimité et on voit bien ici
qu'en fait on patine un petit peu à
trouver cet acte 2 et puis avec cette
impression pierre-adrille à Bartoli qui
est un peu de de je sais pas de temps ou
de camions qui a qui qui avance chacun
de leur côté de stratégie avec le
gouvernement on l'a vu il y a depuis 15
jours on voit beaucoup médiatiquement
parler une saturation médiatique avec
Emmanuel Macron avec ses ministres avec
la première ministre pour voilà
occuper le terrain les 100 jours de mes
sentiments d'une d'un gouvernement en
mouvement et puis il y a la stratégie
syndicale à la stratégie d'opposition
évidemment les Français au milieu de
tout ça est-ce que ils tournent la page
ou pas finalement c'est c'est assez
passionnant parce qu'on est en train de
le mesurer un peu en direct on n'a pas
un essoufflement on a une transformation
d'ailleurs qui a commencé il y a
longtemps hein c'est pas nouveau mais là
elle devient très concrète on mesure un
niveau d'opposition à la réforme des
retraites toujours ma qui était élevé
depuis le départ mais qui l'a recul on a
perdu en gros une dizaine de points ça
reste majoritaire mais ça recule en
revanche le soutien aux manifestations
lui il continue à rester très élevé et
même il progresse pourquoi est-ce qu'on
a cette forme de presque paradoxe parce
que les manifestations aujourd'hui
certes elles traite du sujet des
retraites c'est le point de départ mais
elles ont dépassé les un peu débordé du
cadre ça a commencé c'était très présent
dès le départ ça notamment été beaucoup
plus fort au moment du 49-3 où on est
passé d'une contestation d'une réforme
des retraites à une contestation d'un
mode de gouvernance ou rapport aux
dirigeants et donc peut-être que la page
des retraites commence à être je dirais
pas derrière nous mais mais plutôt du
passé en revanche la crise que ça a
ouvert notamment le rapport à la manière
dont on est gouverné et la société dans
laquelle on vit elle pour le coup elle
ne fait que s'ouvrir la Comté voilà
c'est ça c'est une nouvelle aire de
contestation de certaines façons mais
peut-être quand même que la page se
tourne qu'il y a une intériorisation
même si on va y revenir avec une chance
de de si ce 8 juin c'est peut-être pas
si simple mais une intériorisation que
la réforme est passé j'aurais quand même
on va pas y passer tout le débat mais
qu'on dise un mot des violences qui ont
eu lieu hier lors de ces manifestations
400 plus de 400 policiers gendarmes
blessés Élisabeth borne elle parle d'un
nouveau palier dans les violences est-ce
que est-ce que vous voilà Jean-Marie
comment vous l'analysez ça est-ce que
depuis que je suis tout jeune des
violences des casseurs avant des
éducasseurs bon ça ça va avec les
manifestations et enfin ça fait trois
mois et demi qu'on est dans un dans un
processus manifestant pendant deux trois
mois il y a pas eu de tension de cet
ordre elles ont commencé les violences
après le 49-3 je sais pas si c'est un
hasard mais c'est là que le mouvement
commence à changer un petit peu de
nature comme vous le releviez très
justement et
où là effectivement on voit arriver
c'est ces groupes de casseurs bon je
sais pas il y en avait peut-être 1500 ou
2000 sur toute la France je pense qu'il
faut pas que ça fasse oublier quand même
tout le reste mais non c'est pour ça que
je dis on va pas y passer le débat vous
avez tout à fait raison dans cette idée
alors c'est peut-être de la
communication gouvernementale dans notre
œil mais quand la première mise parle
dame palier vous n'êtes pas d'accord
avec cette idée un peu si là c'était
quand même très nouveau par rapport au
foie précédente donc mais c'est un jeu
dangereux de jouer avec ça parce qu'on
voit que y compris dans les milieux
policiers on commence aussi à parler de
cette responsabilité qui est donnée à la
police de maintenir l'ordre alors que la
question de l'ordre public c'est pas
uniquement une question policière c'est
une question de gestion politique aussi
évidemment et là les doctrine on y a
consacré un débat la semaine dernière
pardon de interrompus j'ai l'impression
que la communication sur le gouvernement
est d'ailleurs on a entendu Gérald
Darmanin et Elisabeth borne s'exprimait
à l'Assemblée aujourd'hui même en
insistant beaucoup il parle pas de la
réforme il parle plus de la réforme des
retraites ils ont parlé que des
violences
ciblé Jean-Luc Mélenchon
en disant je vais le citer à Jean-Luc
Mélenchon qui ne cesse d'exciter tout le
monde entre l'ambiguïté et la complicité
voilà les mots du ministre de
l'intérieur ils prennent beaucoup parce
que c'est vrai qu'on a entendu que
c'était les casseurs on entendait que
c'était 1500 à 2000 casseurs par contre
ce que je trouve plus inquiétant c'est
qu'on a l'impression qu'il y a quand
même des manifestants qui sont plutôt
calmes et plutôt bien encadrés par les
syndicats jusqu'à maintenant il y a un
peu cette tentation gilet jaune en fait
de plus en plus quand on voit dans les
manifestants comme si si ça démarre mais
pourquoi pas j'y vais ce qu'on a
ressenti un petit peu au moment de la
Concorde c'est-à-dire au moment du 49-3
le jeudi quand les jeunes beaucoup de
jeunes se sont retrouvés on sentait que
ça pouvait très rapidement dégénéré avec
des personnes qui sont pas spécialement
des casseurs mais simplement
il y avait pas tant de monde que ça
allait mais il y avait ce côté je suis
très propre sur moi ou quoi mais si ça
dérape j'ai envie d'y aller et je pense
que ce sentiment cette envie elle est
d'autant plus prégnante qui a pas
d'écoute il y a pas de d'inflexion de la
part du gouvernement et ça ça peut être
dangereux parce que ça peut alors
paradicaliser mais donner des envies en
se disant un peu comme pendant les
gilets jaunes c'est à dire bah si si
personne nous entend si on est vraiment
pas écouté s'il y a plus cette
démocratie sociale qu'on et ben on va
aller jusqu'au bout quitte à vraiment ce
que ça soit le bazar et là c'est très
risqué à mon avis pour pour la France
oui je rejoins largement parce que je
pense que ce qu'on ce qu'on constate en
fait dans cette idée du palier donc par
Elisabeth borne c'est qu'il ne faudrait
pas qu'on installe dans la démocratie
l'idée qu'au fond ce n'est que par la
violence qu'on obtient du résultat et on
a beaucoup dit que les gilets jaunes
avaient conduit à un déblocage d'une
enveloppe de 18 millions d'euros ce qui
au fond il y a ce qui est au fond
n'avait pas d'ailleurs donné tellement
l'impression que les gilets jaunes
avaient été entendus sur le moment mais
c'est vrai qu'a posteriori on se dit ça
et donc en fait la l'idéologie de la
violence ça pourrait nous donner
l'impression que il y a moins de
rendez-vous syndicaux il y a moins de
personnes qui se déplacent mais
peut-être des personnes plus
radicalisées avec justement cette idée
dans des coudre un peu comme vous le
disiez c'est à dire bon bah voilà
comment on nous entend plus on va
essayer d'aller directement à la
violence et ça c'est vraiment le danger
qu'installe la communication de face à
face un peu que le gouvernement et les
syndicats installé dans le passé c'est
arrivé que les
la radicalisation ou les scènes de
violence fasse un peu basculer l'opinion
pour l'instant on l'a pas vu ça je sais
pas si c'est tentant de scènes de
violence comme ça depuis le début aussi
enfin on loue plutôt dans les images
qu'on voit dans les commentaires des
cortèges qui sont encadrés par les
syndicats qui sont relativement calmes
la violence c'est vraiment un des points
sinon le point qui fait effectivement la
bascule ça l'a fait au moment des gilets
jaunes c'est l'acte 3 c'est l'acte de
Triomphe c'est le moment où il y a une
vraie bascule dans l'opinion avec
toujours une majorité de personnes qui
soutiennent mais néanmoins une perte de
10 à 15 points de ce soutien c'est à
dire tout ce corps de sympathisant de
centre droit qui était plutôt opposé à
la politique était déjà menée à l'époque
par Emmanuel Macron mais qui se disent
là pour le coup la vulgence va trop loin
je ne peux pas soutenir quand même je
suis contre Emmanuel Macron c'est gilet
jaune et donc il se retire en termes de
soutien et c'est ce qui fait souvent la
la bascule pour objectif un petit peu la
situation ici c'est pas une intéressante
on a grosso modo une majorité de
Français évidemment et de personnes qui
soutiennent les manifestations qui sont
contre la
est-ce que cette majorité doit nous
faire oublier le quart des personnes qui
soutiennent des manifestations et qui
sont enfin qui trouve relativement
légitime que certains y recours à la
violence pour se faire entendre je pense
pas non plus parce qu'on n'est pas sur
des chiffres qui sont anecdotiques et on
est sur tout sur des chiffres qui sont
plus que d'habitude un quart des
personnes interrogées qui soutiennent
qui légitime la violence ont été à peu
près à 20% au moment des gilets jaunes
qui trouvaient que c'était pas
illégitime d'avoir recours à la violence
on est aujourd'hui plutôt sur le car et
au maximum des manifestations ont été
presque à 30%
et peut être assez inquiétant alors je
reviens assez stratégie parallèles et on
va avoir si elles peuvent éventuellement
se rencontrer et comment donc Elizabeth
borne espère avoir autour de d'une table
de négociation le plus de syndicats
possibles Laurent Berger ne ferme pas la
porte mais il pose ses conditions à
l'écoute
et la CFDT et l'IRA discuter mais il ira
discuter en considérant tout coûte plus
cher et qui va avoir maintenant sur les
conditions de travail comme sur la
question salariale quand même sur la
question du dialogue social que des
choses soient mises sur la table qui
soit consistante si c'est le cas on
discutera si c'est pas le cas bah je
crois que le gouvernement n'aura encore
pas compris le gouvernement devra
comprendre que il suffira pas distribuer
trois quatre mesurettes pour pour calmer
la colère sociale je crois qu'on est
dans une colère sociale de de longues de
longue haleine une certaine manière qui
est très ancrée dans le monde du travail
et que pour calmer ça il faudra des
avancées concrètement
Laurent Berger qui passe la main dans
dans quoi deux mois à peu près mais son
syndicat est en position de force on
peut dire ça ce soir bah si on syndicale
tout le mouvement syndical aujourd'hui
est en position de force et je crois que
la CFDT que les autres non
ce mouvement un processus intéressant un
peu de radicalisation enfin on sait que
c'est un syndicat qui traditionnellement
et plutôt ouvert au compromis social
d'ailleurs il le reste je pense sur le
fond le problème c'est que l'espace pour
construire un compromis social c'est
quand même singulièrement et les rétréci
donc et là il fait part de d'exigence
assez forte ils vont pas ils vont pas
ça veut dire quoi coûter plus cher quoi
il va falloir venir avec des
propositions solides sur les questions
de salaire pas seulement discuter de de
la prime enfin des de l'intéressement de
la partie du bastion sur la question des
conditions de travail et encore là je
pense il dit pas tout mais je pense
qu'ils diront si je lis un bien un peu
la presse syndicale c'est revenir sur
une partie des référence Macron on la
suppression des comités d'hygiène
sécurité conditions de travail si on
parle aujourd'hui si on réouvre une
discussion sur le rapport au travail sur
les conditions de travail il faudra
revenir sur sur cet abrogation trouver
enfin oui sur la disparition ils ont des
revendications assez est-ce que le
gouvernement est prêt à aller jusque-là
on verra ça va être intéressant mais je
crois que cette idée que un dialogue
suffira pour les syndicats c'est pas un
dialogue c'est à construire un compromis
pour le gouvernement c'est renouer les
fils avoir une discussion etc mais là
aussi il y a pas que des querelles de
temporalité ce qui pense que on tourne
une page et alors que les syndicats
viennent avec l'idée la mobilisation
d'hier le monde que non on est encore on
est encore dans ce mouvement il faudrait
pas que non plus qu'il y ait une
incompréhension sur le sens de ces
réunions car les uns disant bah on va
communiquer un peu mieux un peu cette
fois-ci essayer de caler une
communication qui soit pas trop
chancelante mais non les syndicats ils y
vont pas pour gérer l'agenda de
communication du Président
est-ce qu'on commence à voir un peu de
un peu de fissure malgré tout c'est en
tout cas les différentes stratégiques
parce que c'est pas si facile d'être le
ça va pas être si facile d'être le
premier syndicat à venir à la table des
négociations s'il y en a un qui va tout
seul vous voyez ce que je veux dire là
qu'on va vivre un moment intéressant en
terme de politique et qu'il s'agisse de
syndicats ou de gouvernement c'est la
même chose c'est une politique de
gestion c'est qui va lâcher et en
quelque sorte en terme d'image être le
premier syndicat à s'asseoir c'est quand
même aussi très difficile à porter au
regard des bases ça veut dire que vous
lâchez quelque chose en tout cas en
termes d'intensité donc oui je crois que
ça sera difficile d'être le premier dans
ce jeu là qu'il s'agisse du gouvernement
du président d'un des syndicats ou d'un
autre c'est-à-dire que on est dans un
bras de fer tellement tendu tellement
solide aujourd'hui que le premier qui va
tendre la main à l'autre apparaît
presque en situation de faiblesse au
regard d'une certaine forme d'opinion
donc renouer les négociations encore une
fois comme vous l'avez dit c'est-à-dire
que tout n'est pas à faire de scénario
autour d'une table parce qu'on a un
petit peu le sentiment on écoute
Elisabeth borne et les différents
ministres que il suffira qu'on soit tous
assis pour qu'il y ait une photo et que
tout soit terminé mais encore une fois
tout sera dans le fond tout sera dans la
manière aussi dont on va négocier cela
il faut pas oublier par exemple qu'en 68
la négociation sociale elle a permis de
déboucher sur les accords de Grenelle
mais notamment avec un véritable
sentiment gouvernemental un travail qui
est allé dans ce sens-là donc
il s'agit pas uniquement de recevoir il
s'agit d'entendre d'écouter et surtout
de donner du résultat donc c'est là à
mon avis que quelque chose se jouera sur
le fond
si on scrute un peu le duo de l'exécutif
puisque Elizabeth borne va se retrouver
là logiquement en première ligne dans
les jours qui viennent avec peut-être
première discussion est-ce qu'elle ils
sont souvent solidaires de surtout avec
le quinquennat le président est son ou
sa première ministre est-ce que ça
change un petit peu aujourd'hui c'est à
peu près le meilleur moment pour poser
la question ça tombe bien j'ai vu
quelques infos avant que avant que
l'émission non mais c'est extrêmement
intéressant c'est en train de se passer
c'est-à-dire qu'on a
suffisant et puis même avant quand on
prend les précédents quinquennat avec
les paires présentialisation donc un
président très exposé un rôle de premier
ministre au moins dans l'opinion qui
ressemble effectivement à cette légumes
premier collaborateur qui accompagne le
président et dans les codes de confiance
on voit ça on voit des niveaux de
confiance qui évoluent à la hausse à la
baisse pour le Premier ministre en même
temps que le président là il s'est passé
quelque chose baromètre qu'on fait tous
les mois avec LCI c'est une
désindexation de la confiance en
Emmanuel Macron d'un côté et d'Emmanuel
et de Isabelle borne de l'autre côté on
a un Emmanuel Macron dans la confiance à
assez nettement baissé depuis le début
de l'année en gros il perd 10 points et
il arrive chez nous à 39% de confiance
et ne les abais de bord qui avait baissé
très fortement en même temps et qui
cette fois ci réaugmente c'est-à-dire
prendre quatre points alors que Manuel
Macron stagne donc elle fait entendre sa
voix un petit peu exactement ce qui est
extrêmement intéressant d'ailleurs cet
aspect là c'est pour la première fois on
a une forme d'identité politique propre
à Elisabeth borne dans l'étude qui se
fait jour qui n'existait pas qu'il n'est
pas perçu par les Français on serait pas
sur le sur le reste qui la voit
désormais comme étant quelqu'un qui a sa
propre identité potentiellement sa
propre ligne et qui cherche son propre
espace et dans cette tendance là vont se
dire qu'elle n'est pas exactement sur la
même ligne que le Président de la
République et qui est grief qui vont
grever la les prochaines semaines ou les
prochains mois du président de la
République quand on voit le rapport de
force dont on vient de parler ne vont
pas forcément toucher en tout cas aussi
fort la première ministre alors à propos
de de ce rapport de force on va prendre
un cas d'école c'est le cas de le dire
vous allez comprendre le jeu de mots
tout de suite on va parler de la réforme
du lycée
on va prendre donc cet exemple là parce
que c'est une mesure phare du président
il en a parlé dans son allocution du 17
avril ça faisait partie de ces chantiers
prioritaires on sait que ça lui tient à
cœur il devrait d'ailleurs présenter ses
intentions en tout cas les détailler
lors d'un déplacement qui serait
organisé cette semaine mais c'est encore
top secret parce que castrola d'oblige
on essaie de se méfier et de dire son
ordre du jour son emploi du temps au
dernier moment vous l'avez choisi ce
thème Émilie parce que c'est ça nous
éclaire sur les relations entre
l'exécutif et les syndicats oui parce
que le sujet est assez épineux ça a déjà
commencé un petit peu les concertations
en gros le gouvernement souhaite un peu
comme il a fait pour l'apprentissage
faciliter le passage des élèves de lycée
pro dans la vie active en gros
raccourcir ce délai là donc réduire au
passage le chômage c'est une pratique
qui est inspirée de notre modèle préféré
outrer rein en Allemagne et c'est ce
qu'il a fait sur l'apprentissage qui a
plutôt pas mal réussi jusque là mais
depuis le début déconcertations qui ont
été lancés en octobre 2022 les syndicats
sont très remontés contre la réforme
pour eux c'est impossible d'envisager
d'augmenter la durée les heures de stage
que font les élèves donc dans les
entreprises au détriment de leur
apprentissage théorique pour eux c'est
pas ça le but du jeu et c'est surtout
impensable de faire penser cette
thématique sous la coupe du ministère du
Travail et non plus de l'éducation
nationale on comprend bien ce qu'il y a
derrière sur le premier mois point sur
les stages le gouvernement a reculé
parce que les syndicats sont assez
mobilisés il y a eu quelques
manifestations qui ont été un petit peu
mis de côté par rapport à la réforme des
retraites en tout cas il a reculé il y
aura pas d'augmentation de la rue durée
des stages sur le second point par
contre l'annonce d'un projet de loi
d'ici l'été fait craindre le pire au
syndicats qui l'ont vite exprimé ils ont
fait un communiqué de presse toutes les
syndicats de l'éducation nationale en
disant un peu à la manière de Laurent
Berger sauf que ne veulent pas venir à
la table déconcertations pour le moment
pour l'élaboration du texte pour eux le
cadre est trop contraint c'est une
espèce de marche forcée qui est annoncée
et leurs avis ne sont pas pris en compte
et là je vois un petit parallèle avec la
réforme des retraites puisque finalement
c'est exactement la même chose qui s'est
passé une concertation un peu similaire
avec un cadre très contraint et
finalement on sait ce que c'est ce qui
se passe les syndicats out le 49.3 qui
passe et puis les difficultés qu'on
connaît jusqu'à maintenant
de méthode alors Emmanuel Macron si on
écoute bien dans ces petits débats il
avait déjà donné des signaux sur son
long changement de méthode de
fonctionnement ou de non fonctionnement
avec les syndicats malgré ses promesses
c'était notamment sur le la rémunération
des enseignants donc il a donné le pacte
dans un de ces débats il a insisté sur
cette idée de pacte si je travaille plus
je gagne plus pour les enseignants et en
l'occurrence les syndicats étaient
complètement opposés à cette mesure il
est même parti de la table des
négociations à le président quand même a
décidé d'annoncer ça dans ces débats et
sans tenir compte de la vie des
syndicats leur demande de discussion n'a
pas tenu lieu et seul contre tous il a
continué à avancer ses réformes moi je
me demande jusqu'à quel moment ça peut
durer et puis on le voit avec ces
discussions sur les syndicats qui
viennent ou qui viennent pas d'autant
que le gouvernement comme on le répète à
longueur de journée n'a pas de majorité
à l'Assemblée nationale donc ne peut pas
tracer comme ça seul avec l'Assemblée et
puis il a pas d'allier de confiance qui
pourrait permettre de faire voter voter
les lois donc avancer sans les syndicats
sans majorité ça commence à devenir
compliqué et on sait qu'il y a encore
quatre ans à tenir j'en aurais Pernaut
peut-être sur les syndicats
d'enseignants est-ce que de toute façon
c'est ils sont pas rétifs par principe à
toute forme de négociations à chaque
fois qu'il y a un nouveau ministre il y
a de nouvelles réformes ils en ont marre
quoi il est vrai qu'à chaque fois qu'un
ministre on a droit à des réformes donc
le changement permanent donc au bout
d'un moment il y a un manque de
continuité assez évident mais non il y a
eu des accords signés dans dans
l'éducation nationale bon là je crois
qu'on est sur un point dur quand même
avec cette histoire du lycée
professionnel on les a rarement vu aussi
remontés quand même contre une réforme
ils ont souvent des accords il y en a
qui signe d'autres qui signent pas même
la FSU qui passe au moins facilement
signataires et là signe des accords dans
l'éducation nationale mais là je crois
que ça touche sur un point auquel les
syndicats sont très sensibles ça pose la
question des 100 jours puis Adrien
Bartoli ce rythme là que Emmanuel Macron
a inventé alors c'est sans doute pas mal
de communication évidemment mais est-ce
que les Français y croient comment c'est
reçu ça
une forme de démonétisation pardon du
terme un peu de la parole publique ou de
la parole présidentielle a annoncé ça et
puis assez vite on se rend compte que
pas si simple projet de l'immigration
finalement c'est pas pour tout de suite
etc il y a deux aspects c'est-à-dire
un des problèmes que rencontrer Emmanuel
Macron en termes d'images actuellement
elle porte la tue elle porte sur sa
crédibilité sa capacité à faire changer
les choses si la tenue sa base jusqu'à
présent c'était notamment pour ça pour
des qualités personnelles qui lui
étaient reconnues bien sûr mais
également parce qu'on pensait qu'il
était la bonne personne ou la moins pire
dans un climat de défiance pour mener à
bien les projets réformer le pays et
malgré tout appliquer les la politique
il avait promis lors de son sa première
élection et de sa réélection ensuite là
on sent qu'il commence à y avoir un
doute d'ailleurs un doute qui touche y
compris son cœur d'électorat et ce qui
fait qu'il fait plus totalement le plein
dans nos enquêtes et on se rend compte
qu'une partie petite pour l'instant mais
une partie néanmoins à peu près 15% de
ces de ses plus proches comment savoir
un doute sur ce qui peut faire mais sur
la question des 100 jours on peut
prendre à l'envers s'il avait pas donné
cet échéance là on n'avait pas de
débouchés politiques et la vraie utilité
de ces 100 jours c'est ça c'est dire
qu'après cette confrontation
bloque contre bloc syndicat contre
contre gouvernement
rue contre pouvoir on allait pouvoir se
retrouver et se donner rendez-vous à un
certain point pour faire une forme de
bilan et cette forme de bilan c'est un
débouché politique ça avait été les
grands débats les conférences en région
et puis la restitution après les gilets
jaunes c'est les 100 jours en tout cas
labellisés comme tel désormais mais
c'est surtout ça c'est donner une
perspective donner un objectif et
surtout se donner de l'air Anne Charlène
justement est-ce que ça n'est pas un
problème comme ça quand les majorités
s'auto donne des rendez-vous
d'auto-évaluation je crois que c'est un
peu risqué d'autant qu'en plus cette
majorité a pas mal de mal avec les
résultats vous parliez de l'exemple et
du parallèle des grands débats ce débat
devait donner une loi qui n'est jamais
arrivée pour cause d'incendie Notre-Dame
de Paris on a eu ensuite le vrai
problème du résultat avec la convention
citoyenne ou finalement la récupération
politique pas été à la hauteur du
rendez-vous et le seul président de la
République qui s'était donné un
leitmotiv c'était François Hollande en
disant de toute façon mon quinquennat
sera celui de la baisse du chômage et
finalement on sait que c'est à cause de
ça qu'il n'a pas estimé qu'il avait la
légitime légitimité pour se représenter
donc est-ce que c'est vraiment un Paris
gagnant politiquement de ce fixer un cap
comme ça en se donnant des jours en
disant voilà je prends les
responsabilités il faudra qu'il y ait
des résultats entre temps je crois quand
même que c'est un peu à double tranchant
notamment par rapport au fait que il
faut que ça corresponde à un calendrier
parlementaire que pour le moment on
peine avoir venir parler justement du
calendrier parlementaire tout de suite
vous vouliez prendre la parole vraiment
rapidement pour aller de tout à fait
dans ce sens là d'autant qu'on le voit
bien au fil des mots d'ordre dans les
manifestations parce que ça correspond
un petit peu à ce que vous disiez tout à
l'heure sur la réforme je crois pas que
ce soit qu'elle soit qu'elle est qu'elle
est digérer même mais parce que quand
même 62 64 c'est pas digéré mais
le mouvement se déplace quand même et je
crois qu'aujourd'hui ça a tendance on le
voit dans les mots d'ordre à se foc sur
ici le problème c'était pas Macron parce
que vraiment il y a un niveau de rejet
et qui alimenté par il est tout à fait
manifestement incapable de changer de
méthode et c'est ça qui apparaît de plus
en plus et ce qu'on peut conduire un
pays durablement comme vous le disiez
sans majorité parlementaire en piétinant
à peu près tout ce qui
imaginable en termes de corps
intermédiaires est-ce que vraiment on
peut diriger d'ailleurs il y en a
certains qui disent qu'il dirigent la
France comme une entreprise mais je
pense que même à diriger une entreprise
comme ça on va au devant de pas mal de
catastrophes alors vous évoquez le
calendrier parlementaire on en parle
tout de suite grâce à Quentin calmé qui
nous rejoint sur ce plateau bonsoir
Quentin le Parlement qui a repris son
travail aujourd'hui après 15 jours de
d'interruption et on n'en sait plus là
sur la feuille de route des deux
chambres voilà puisque c'est vrai qu'on
pouvait le dire le Sénat et l'Assemblée
nationale tournait un peu au ralenti
depuis le vote de la réforme des
retraites les commissions avaient bien
continué leur travail mais les textes
inscrits en séance publique était
principalement d'initiative
parlementaire
donc avec moins d'enjeux politiques on
peut le dire depuis le report de la loi
immigration renvoyé à l'automne prochain
on attendait aussi de savoir quel serait
les prochains grands textes législatif
présenter et examinés donc depuis
mercredi et la présentation de la
feuille de route d'Elizabeth borne sur
les 100 jours et bien on connaît enfin
les prochains textes écoutez la priorité
fixée par la première ministre en
conférence de presse
au cours de ces 100 jours on montre aux
français qu'on entend leur priorité leur
préoccupations et qu'on accélère des
textes très concrets pour les Français
ce qu'on en prend le chemin n'a pas
exactement regarder l'agenda des
prochaines semaines fixez donc pour les
députés ce matin ils le sera pour les
sénateurs mardi prochain alors tout va
s'accélérer à partir du 22 mai
véritablement l'Assemblée nationale sont
pas rare alors du projet de loi de
programmation militaire pour deux
semaines en séance d'augmenter on le
saitement on en a évoqué ici les grandes
lignes dans cette émission le budget des
armées sur la période 2024 2030 dans le
même temps la loi de programmation de la
justice d'Éric Dupond-Moretti vous le
voyez et bien elle commencera son
parcours parlementaire au Sénat cela
signifie tout de même que depuis la
mi-mace et donc pendant deux mois le
Parlement n'avait pas examiné de grands
textes importants et alors les autres
textes à venir d'ici l'été qu'est-ce
qu'on en sait alors les députés
devraient ensuite enchaîner avec un
texte sur le partage de la valeur en
entreprise pour fixer dans la loi
l'accord fixer cet hiver votre
partenaire sociaux la question n'en ai
parlé dans cette émission de leur côté
les sénateurs devraient s'emparer d'un
texte défendu par Bruno Le Maire
consacré au développement de l'industrie
verte puis celui sur les doigts et les
oeuvres spoilées enfin projet de loi sur
le numérique réforme du lycée
professionnel recrute Mendes assistants
médicaux projets de globe pleine emploi
qui transforme Pôle emploi en France
travail tous ces textes que vous voyez à
l'écran il devrait être présenté examiné
d'ici à mi-juillet car le Parlement
pourrait suspendre ces travaux assez tôt
le Sénat a en effet demandé au
gouvernement de suspendre les travaux
autour du 14 juillet pourquoi pour
entamer la campagne des sénatoriales et
bon ça tombe aussi bien puisque c'est là
où le chef d'État voulait fixer aussi et
bien le bilan des 100 jours le bilan des
100 jours merci Quentin Charles Bezina
est-ce que on voit ces textes et ce
qu'ils peuvent passer 149-3 parce que
elle va revenir elle va revenir à chaque
à chaque présentation d'une nouvelle
réforme à l'Assemblée finalement c'est
en effet la grande question c'est fin de
majorité de projet on le sait le seul
exemple que nous avons c'est 88 où il
était aisé pour ce gouvernement de
gauche d'arriver à déborder sur la
gauche de la gauche ou au contraire à
déborder au centre voire même à parfois
attraper les deux suivant des jeux de
mots que Guy Carcassonne avait inventé
stéréo Dolby etc en fonction des
majorités ici c'est difficile d'arriver
à trouver des partenaires sur des textes
aussi alors elle est arrivée Isabelle
mais qui était relativement consensuel
sur le pouvoir d'achat etc ici on a
quand même abandonné les projets les
plus clivants mais on se rend compte que
et notamment beaucoup de loi de
programmatiques ou de loi qui vont
entamer
une démarche longue sur les projections
et là-dessus c'est parfois difficile de
se mettre d'accord donc ce privé de la
possibilité du 49-3 ça paraît parfois un
petit peu dommage d'autant qu'en réalité
il semble que c'est pour ça que la loi
de réforme des retraites est passée par
une loi de financement de la sécurité
sociale rectificative pour garder cette
cartouche du 49-3 session ordinaire donc
on comprend mal pourquoi la première
ministre veut s'en priver néanmoins
c'est vrai qu'en termes de méthode
aujourd'hui le 49-3 est associé un petit
peu à la présidence jupitérienne il est
devenu voilà il est devenu non
seulement alors très souvent il y a une
confusion en croyant que c'est un outil
présidentiel alors que c'est un outil
primo gouvernemental et surtout il est
devenu un petit peu le symbole de cette
présidence par le haut alors arrivé à
trouver des consensus c'est vraiment
tout ce qu'on peut souhaiter à la
première ministre pour montrer qu'il est
possible de gouverner avec une
majoritaire lative oui je me disais par
rapport à tous les sujets qui sont
traités c'est quand même particulier
parce qu'on n'a pas véritablement de cap
qui se dessinent le cap des 100 jours
c'est juste les 100 jours c'est je fais
un bilan pour parler de tout ça donc
c'est un espèce de peau pourri de plein
de mesures qui peuvent être
intéressantes chantiers annoncé
on comprend bien pourquoi parce qu'il y
a pas de majorité donc il peut pas faire
passer une loi un peu d'ampleur qui
donnerait une vision je sais pas on
arrête pas de parler de la transition
énergétique par exemple ou écologique il
y a pas tellement des signaux mis à part
dans la voix d'Elizabeth band par-ci par
là aujourd'hui encore à l'Assemblée mais
il y a pas cette vision là donc il se
prive de ça je pense que si on veut
réconcilier les uns et les autres et
embarquer une population il faut un peu
faire rêver c'est pas fait par rêver il
se prive de d'éventuellement pouvoir
communiquer sur des résultats comment
voulez-vous avec une assemblée qui va
vraiment commencer à travailler là dans
15 jours et arriver au 14 juillet
qu'est-ce qui va avoir comme résultat
marqué dans la vie des uns et des autres
il pourra pas afficher donc pas de
vision
il s'est tendu un piège à mon avis il a
besoin de se donner ça parce qu'il a pas
trouvé il a pas trouvé le truc il a pas
trouvé le truc comme le grand débat
comme tout ce qu'il a pu trouver parce
qu'il est très ingénieux ce Président il
est très brillant mais là cette fois-ci
il veut pas lâcher contrairement aux
gilet jaune il a pas trouvé le truc pour
relancer son son quinquennat là et même
déjà pour le lancer tout court je crois
qu'en 2022 déjà il était un peu sec en
proposition c'était déjà des choses très
terre à terre qui ont pas fait rêver et
encore moins la réforme
électorale donc on a beaucoup analysé
ici à vide voilà il y a deux échéances
attendues par les opposants à la réforme
le référendum d'initiative partagé et
puis la proposition en deux doigts je
l'évoquais tout à l'heure du goût plus
haute pour abroger
64 ans écoutez ce qu'on dit Olivier
Faure le premier secrétaire du Parti
socialiste on va continuer à l'assembler
puisque nous avons un premier
rendez-vous le 3 mai pour savoir si le
rip le second RIP est accepté ou pas et
puis nous aurons dans une niche
parlementaire prochaine aussi à débattre
de l'abrogation vous êtes loin et donc
de faire en sorte que le vote que le
gouvernement n'a pas voulu avoir une
première fois et bien nous puissions
l'avoir cette fois-ci et montrer que ce
gouvernement n'a ni majorité dans la rue
ni dans le monde syndical c'est une
évidence mais pas davantage à
l'Assemblée alors le référendum
d'initiative partagé la décision du
Conseil conditionnel elle a lieu demain
on en parlera longuement demain dans
cette émission première partie je
voudrais qu'on se concentre un peu sur
la proposition de loi du groupe liotte
pour abroger la réforme et donc revenir
aux 62 ans il profite je vais rester
avec vous un Charline il profite on va
l'expliquer de leur niche parlementaire
c'est dans plus d'un mois on n'a pas
fini de compter les voix et de faire des
hypothèses sur ce plateau et sur
d'autres
elle pourrait être adoptée cette
proposition de loi c'est pas la même la
même configuration que la motion de
censure il faut le redire en quelques
mots qui est important c'est que une
proposition de loi c'est la force de
proposition du Parlement en tant que tel
et donc en fait on est dans un jeu ici
tout à fait inédit sous la Cinquième
République où on a eu un projet de loi
d'initiative gouvernementale qui est à
ce point-là rejetée par l'Assemblée
nationale qu'elle utilise sa capacité de
proposition pour revenir sur ce qui
vient d'être décidé d'accord alors on a
vu quand même que les oppositions
avaient eu du mal à se coaliser ici mais
le 49-3 c'est un renversement
gouvernemental ce qui a quand même une
charge politique très forte notamment
pour les LR qui n'a pas la même
signification ici ça voudrait quand même
dire qu'il faut trouver une majorité de
personnes pour déconstruire ce qui vient
d'être voté par l'Assemblée nationale et
notamment en réalité il faudrait arriver
à démontrer que la majorité est hostile
à ce projet de réforme alors ça sera
forcément pas le cas au Sénat à
l'Assemblée nationale ça peut être just
mais on va dire qu'en terme de
communication politique ça permet
surtout de dire le débat n'est pas
terminé nous avons encore des ressources
et c'était je crois le président de la
CGT kinéait on a pu rassure tous les
boutons et bien ça prouve vraiment que
cette opposition elle veut vraiment
appuyer sur tous les boutons donc tout
ce qui existe dans un cycle législatif
sera actionné et c'est surtout ça la
force de cette propriété on verra bien
effectivement mais c'est ce qui est
intéressant j'aimerais perdre ça donne
finalement à l'Inter syndical et aussi
aux parties des oppositions de gauche on
va dire mais cet espoir que finalement
cette réforme même si elle a été
légalement bon on peut on peut critiquer
les outils constitutionnels qui ont été
mis en oeuvre pour la faire passer mais
bon elle a été elle a été adoptée et ben
peut-être que
elle est elle est pas encore totalement
mis en oeuvre pour les français ce qui
est d'ailleurs pas si simple pour enfin
moi je suis dans ce cas là mais il y a
beaucoup de noter les spectateurs qui
veulent allergiques qui se disent
finalement à quelle chose je vais être
manger est-ce que je vais devoir bosser
trois mois de plus
il y a cette incertitude qui qui reste
dans l'air là c'est à la fois un
avantage stratégique et une inconfort
une forme d'inconfort pour les français
pour certains Français oui bien sûr ça
crée de sacré de l'incertitude mais pour
la mobilisation sociale c'est très
important de créer cette incertitude
parce que ce qu'on voit au fil des
mobilisations c'est qu'il y a de plus en
plus de gens qui viennent dans les
défilés en étant sûr que Macron bougera
pas comme comme ils le disait qu'en fait
il y a beaucoup de gens qui viennent un
peu par dignité le sentiment de dignité
d'ailleurs la fameuse chanson on est là
on est là qui est hérité des gilets
jaunes qu'elle sait on est là pour la
dignité des travailleurs et pour
construire un monde meilleur je crois il
y a bien ces deux aspects là c'est en
positif mais aussi et aussi s'affirmer
je crois que la mobilisation a besoin
pour être scandé d'échéance comme ça qui
font aussi d'ailleurs l'articulation
entre le social et le politique
puisqu'on voit bien quand même que les
syndicats sont attentifs aux
institutions pour eux les institutions
jouent un rôle et le se voit confier une
responsabilité de dénouer ce qui veut
comme une crise de légitimité d'une
décision publique sans majorité
parlementaire donc je crois que ça pour
eux c'est effectivement un support
important bon ça met un peu
d'incertitude mais au fond ça les soucis
en dernier espoir donc c'est pas
forcément négatif je sais pas si vous
l'avez sondé ça cette notion
d'incertitude c'est-à-dire que voilà
pour les millions de Français qui sont
concernés par par la réforme des
retraites se dire bah bon on nous dit ça
va être pour septembre sauf que c'est
peut-être pas c'est peut-être pas
complètement sûr comment commencer c'est
reçu on la passe on est directement mais
ce qui est ce qui est intéressant à
suivre ça va être la capacité des
responsables politiques d'opposition
d'une part et syndicaux d'autre part à
comprendre la nature de l'opposition qui
va avoir lieu et on aura notamment des
signes bon son d'Agis certes mais
également dans la manifestation du 6
juin qui a été annoncé
je ne sais pas si on peut durer très
longtemps en tout cas si une opposition
sur cette mesure d'âge ou plus
globalement cette réforme des retraites
peut durer très longtemps et si elle se
transforme en autre chose qui à mon avis
est en train de passer actuellement
est-ce qu'on risque pas de sonner un peu
à côté du sujet dans un mois quand on
reviendra à la charge sur ce thème là il
est important
de se transformer et une sorte de pas en
arrière c'est la tension c'est le point
d'attention qui va falloir avoir de leur
part à ce moment-là pour pas sembler un
peu dissonant et un peu en décalage avec
ce qui sera jugé du moment et ce qui
sera le sujet du moment ça peut être
cette question de la fronde antimacron
qui prend très fortement qui s'en racine
dans les mois et les années passées
parce qu'elle vient pas de naître
maintenant ça peut être aussi un autre
aspect qu'on connaît qui est extrêmement
latent et quand on sent des priorités
des Français ça arrive très nettement en
première place largement devant la
réforme des retraites c'est toujours et
encore cette question du pouvoir d'achat
dont les Français ont l'impression
qu'elle n'est pas traitée et plus le
temps passe plus elle a l'air de passer
au second plan pour des dirigeants
politiques qui sont vus comme des élites
éloignés coupés des réalités alors que
les Français la vie au quotidien mais
est-ce que alors je vais pousser le
bouchon est-ce que ça voudrait que que
une partie de l'opinion pourrait en
vouloir
aux oppositions qui qui freinent
l'avancée de la de la réforme des
retraites et qui empêche le gouvernement
de passer à autre chose allez on se
projette très loin vraiment le bouchon
et on pousse un peu le bouchon mais ceci
dit c'est une question elle va se poser
la question on va quand même se poser
est-ce qu'on est encore sur cette
réforme là qu'on peut avec laquelle on
sera on est en désaccord et on
continuera à l'aise on attaque les
Français du jour au lendemain faut
changer d'avis sur cette réforme ou
est-ce que le contestation va changer de
nature et dans ce cas-là l'opposition
devra peut-être s'y adapter évidemment
le la configuration politique à
l'Assemblée elle est quand même très
inédite mais c'est déjà arrivé de
revenir aussi vite sur un texte qui
vient d'être adopté finalement non
amener à des abrogations assez rapides
comme par exemple la succession Nicolas
Sarkozy François Hollande sur le
conseiller que le conseiller commence à
platine ce conseiller territorial voilà
entre le département et la région on a
eu aussi les nationalisations et les
privatisations de majorité donc non
c'est inédit et pas du tout en plus
l'idée de véhiculer une espèce de guerre
projet de loi contre proposition de loi
qui jusqu'à présent n'est jamais arrivé
sous la 5e République et ça veut dire
quelque chose de l'équilibre des
pouvoirs on a dit beaucoup de se débat
de la retraite qu'il avait
court-circuité l'Assemblée nationale et
ça prouve qu'elle veut tout simplement
faire entendre sa voix et ce groupe
liote qui finalement a été d'ailleurs
une cheville ouvrière au moment de la
motion de censure continue à endosser ce
rôle de groupe suffisamment central pour
associer des groupes extrêmes qui est
quand même tout à fait inédit et très
intéressant dans la contestation et dans
la coalition d'une opposition
constructive ça peut être très dangereux
pour le gouvernement merci beaucoup
merci à tous d'avoir participé à ce
premier débat Jean-Marie Pernaut je
rappelle le titre de votre livre le
syndicalisme d'après qui est donc publié
aux éditions le détour